par marque par ce plan de relance moi je
trouve pas qu'il est insuffisant je
trouve qu'il est excessif
au contraire cette idée que on va
pouvoir dépenser les milliards 100
milliards 200 millions à 300 milliards
je pense que ça effraie la population on
lui a dit il ya un an qu'on pouvait pas
se permettre de laisser le régime de
retraite avoir 12 à 13 milliards de
déficit et maintenant on lui dit on peut
dépenser 100 milliards et des gens lui
disent mais pourquoi s'arrêter à 100
milliards pourquoi pas 120 pourquoi pas
s'en prendre et je crois que c'est non
seulement aberrant aux yeux de la
population même anxiogène et donc on
commence à voir effectivement vous le
dis que la population ne dépense pas le
cours de l'or monte
il ya toute une partie de la population
mondiale qui commence à s'inquiéter de
cette masse d'argent dont on ne sait pas
d'où il vient et qui est annoncé comme
pouvant être dépensés comme ça sans
aucune conséquence
le deuxième élément c'est que je pense
encore une fois que dans l'immédiat ce
qui s'est passé c'est qu'on n'a pas
travaillé et donc l'enjeu c'est de se
remettre au travail il faut produire et
donc l'enjeu c'est pas de dépenser mais
de permettre aux entreprises de
travailler et je crois que des anges
clair ça devrait être de dire une bonne
fois pour toutes les conditions dans
lequelles va pouvoir travailler ses
terres est ce qu'il faut un masque pas
masquer ce que comment est ce qu'on va
pouvoir s'organiser et je crois que ça
ça doit être négocié aussi au niveau
local que les entreprises se saisisse de
cette affaire et que c'est pas ça relève
pas d'un plan de relance et la troisième
marque que je ferai c'est que
concrètement le capital n'a pas été
détruit et le pouvoir d'achat
potentiellement existe vous le disiez il
ya deux il ya de l'argent et donc je
crois que le véritable enjeu c'est de
rétablir véritablement une forme de
confiance dès que le déconfinement eu
lieu c'est remonter très vite âge
rappelle que en avril 60% de l'appareil
de production a été utilisé et en
juillet on était remonté 75% de
l'appareil de production alors que en
temps normal en est à 82% de l'appareil
de production dont il ya une capacité
tout de suite de réponse et mais cette
réponse est suppose que effectivement il
ya une lecture et une donne est claire
de ce que la politique que l'on mène et
l'idée effectivement que ça repose sur
les entreprises et pas sur cette espèce
de valse des milliards dont tu en sais
pas d'où ils viennent dont on sait pas
ce qu'on va en faire et qui sont
référencés la conversion écologique que
la solidarité la souveraineté tout ça
est extrêmement confus et je pense que
c'est plus négatif que véritablement
porteur d'avenir
j
[Musique]